hello everyone this is amir from audio
science review i have another
potentially controversial review for you
uh namely an isolation transformer this
one's uh from a company called trip lite
uh it's the is-250 is their 250 volt amp
isolation transformer i would say it's
probably the most common uh most popular
isolation transformer that people buy
it's a good brand here's the one i
bought 130 ratings on amazon
it costs 140 as you can see i bought it
uh a few weeks ago or a few months ago
at this rate um the reason i bought it
was that we were discussing my
measurements of uh and review of other
power products and somebody said well
how about these isolation transformers
do they make your
audio system sound better
i said well i don't think it is so i'm
not going to spend my money on it but if
somebody else wants to spend their money
i'll go ahead and test it and indeed
somebody was kind enough to do that so i
went ahead and purchased it and uh only
now getting around to testing it um as
the name indicates there's a transformer
inside this is the box itself let me get
it
it's quite heavy
our
this spot being small is quite heavy uh
and you can see it's got a nice on off
switch in the front
and in the back it has two outlets
and a
standard thick iec uh
ic had one end cable um
for my arm brakes
um a strong preface i posted this review
last night and the classic
misunderstandings happen
my goal in testing products like this is
to see if the audio fidelity is improved
meaning the classical thing people say
they buy one of these things power
cables condition or what have you and
they say the background got blacker
sound stage got bigger the eyes become
smoother sound became more analog like
that's what i'm addressing in here i'm
not addressing the case where somebody
has had some hum and buzz or whatever
and got one of these and it happened to
fix that issue
if you have human buzz
posts on a forum will walk you through
and people will give you correct advice
on on what to look for and
the best defense against that as i've
said before is balanced interconnects uh
but if you've made a mistake of using
rca
then uh you know there are issues to be
resolved
but uh um stepping back why these
products have such high appeal excuse me
to audiophiles is because the name
isolation
you know people automatically think
there's a moat in there that keeps all
the bad stuff in ac out of the uh your
audio product and all the great stuff
comes out the other side um and on paper
that seems to be true in that insider
transformers there's two coils uh just
windings of wire
and
an iron core and that
magnetically sends a signal from this
side to the other side in this case
signals 60 hertz and mains input because
it's ac
it
sort of jumps and
it goes from electrical to magnetic back
to electrical on the other side the turn
ratio is one to one meaning what you put
in is what you get so you get 120 in you
get 120 out of 240 and you get 240 out
but if the input goes up and down the
output goes up and down with it so right
away this is not what you think which is
oh there's this rock solid thing in here
and the one on the left side doesn't do
anything
and specifically and i'll show you if
any kind of noise is ac
it will also transmit a subject any
filtering that may exist in the device
now if you go read the amazon reviews
you immediately notice a major issue
with this and that is the fact that if
you uh let me get this guy back again
you see that this has a three pin outlet
i mean three pin plug and it's got a
grounding uh safety ground uh pin in
here
and it has the same thing in here
uh it's a three pin connections not two
pin
and i won't bother showing you but if
you put a meter across this pin
and the
safety ground in here they're both
connected together
so
if they're connected together there's no
isolation right anything that goes on
that save the ground travels right
through to the other side and the safety
ground in your meter in your panel for
your house at least in the u.s it's
connected right to the neutral as well
so
while there's some isolation in here of
you know of uh
in there but the the
main thing people buy it for it doesn't
do that
it is not isolated it carries the safety
ground from input to output so if you
have a ground loop that's caused by that
and
you plug this in it will not make any
difference if anything it adds more
length and could potentially cause noise
problems that you didn't have before
and uh so that's a mistake number one
now people immediately tell you how to
hack these devices and remove that
um
so
there is an application for that where
that's kind of valid but you gotta be
very careful in that if you have uh
you're doing repairing audio
repairing electronics
on a workbench and your instrumentation
is ground reference like the
oscilloscope i have the
shield in it is actually connected to
the same safety ground
if you connect that to a hot signal on
on the device that you're testing you
get a short and really bad things happen
so in that application you do want true
isolation so people open these boxes and
disconnect that connection that goes
from input to output
the moment you do that first you violate
this ul certification which is safety
certification because now if one of
these hot wires comes loose and connects
and touches the chassis of this metal
device
the chassis can get hot and your circuit
breaker will not pop which means you
touch this thing you could get you know
nasty shock or get electrocuted so
right away you violated the the
safety
protocol of this device furthermore your
target device if it's a three pin device
that connected to this
its chassis is no longer got any safety
ground protection either because you
disconnected that this pin will no
longer be connected to anything
so if some hot wire gets disconnected
inside there and connects to the chassis
then again you created you know shock
hazard and
you're basically defeating decades of
proper conduct and code that says why
this pin is there now if you have a two
pin a double insulated device that won't
happen but that's much more rare in
audio than than the three pin variety
now in the context of doing a repair in
the hands of a technician or engineer
that knows what he's doing and he's only
doing this for a few hours or repairing
something
it's accepted press practice and it's
necessary most of the time because you
got a device that is ground is at high
potential you know how else you're going
to work on it so
in the in that limited use scenario
where you're in control you're
you know somebody with knowledge of
electricity
working on stuff it's fine in just a few
hours you can repair something put it
away
whereas if you're going to hook
something up leave it as in your stereo
that's a completely different animal
where you're going to go on day in day
out that way and things can deteriorate
and they can be you know just just luck
of the draw that uh you know some bad
could happen in the one unit that you
have that doesn't have proper safety
protection
so
in no way
you know should you go in there and and
do the hack that people are talking
about most of those people are again
correctly talking about it and using it
for technician use for repairing things
but please do not go take this device
remove the hacksaw okay now i made it
totally isolated
now i'll show you in a minute where that
will help you anyway as far as your
fidelity but know that this is you know
this is a misnomer in there by the
company trip light even though i like
their products i think this is well
built device i use their uh power strips
and so forth
i just think it's a it's just improper
to not emphasize that this is you know
true it's not isolated i mean it's what
what goes on the input on this ground
pin
you know on this side comes out here so
there's no true isolation of the three
pins is presented uh on this thing so
uh that's the key thing in here i want
to make sure nobody's understood
misunderstands it now our purpose in
here as i said isn't to investigate
electrical devices for the sake of
electrical device analysis that you know
we're not called electrical science
review we're called audio science review
my goal is to figure out you know do
these things improve the sound because a
lot of people read that an isolation
transformer is something that sounds
good to them as i said and plug it in
and they report improvements on these
things so they put improvements on a lot
of things
so as usual i start by measuring my
incoming ac
with my
high voltage
differential probe which means that it
doesn't pick up noise on its own and
measure my acm my ac is as dirty as ever
this number i think goes up and down
some percentage point but basically this
is 60 hertz coming in and then these are
all the unwanted things if you will
all these distortions and noise and
that's just normal so if you were to
treat this as a audio device it has a
sign of the 31 db
on this thing is 60 hertz you can see
and again this voltage you have to
multiply by 100 to get the true voltage
so it's
123.7 volts
okay
um now let's measure what happens if i
take that exact same power and running
it through the trip light
isolation transformer
we have a positive right away in that
this noise floor starts to get much
slower at higher frequencies look at the
slope in here now let me go back you can
see this gentle over here so there's
definitely high frequency filtering and
happen and that's the nature of the
thing you've got a big inductor in there
and you've got
capacitance in there and you have
coupling inefficiencies and it all
actually helps to reduce high
frequencies but here's the kick here if
you have a linear tr audio transfer uh
linear power supply in your audio
equipment it's doing the same thing
so all this time people think oh wow i
got all this noise i got to filter no
that transformed inside your equipments
or
that filtering and there's tons more
filtering in your other equipment as
i've explained before but importantly
all these nastiness that's much higher
amplitude over here they have not
changed so as a result our cyanide
hasn't changed and uh um voltage has i
think 1.26 now it's just that's just
normal variation um but there are some
losses which i didn't measure because
you a
transformer in the middle and those
white things have resistances and you
will lose some power so don't plug in
high power equipment this one's too
small anyway for me to have hooked up
any power equipment
so but importantly look at how you know
we have the formation of the ac sine
wave over here on the tips here and we
had the same deformation before so
nothing got magically better all the
junk that was in the original
signal if you will the ac power
ran right through the thing as i
explained so other than some high
frequency filtering
you know not nothing happened there um
on this deck
so um i went ahead and did a high
bandwidth test that has this test only
it goes to 22 kilohertz audible band but
some people make arguments about higher
frequencies so let's go and test it up
to 90 kilohertz
and here we clearly see the effect of
the filtering that it provides or which
is inversely lack of bandwidth
on this thing you can see that it
lowered the noise floor here
of ac
by this amount but here actually in this
middle it actually made things a little
bit worse you can't tell over here but
these spikes are actually taller than
raw ac the reason for that is that this
is a non-linear device that magnetic
field is not a perfect magnetic field it
saturates and unsaturates and so it
actually adds its own distortions to the
signal so it actually makes things worse
in where your hearing is more sensitive
ironically uh but improves the higher
frequencies uh on this thing
but key thing as always as a reminder is
that those are ac measurements we don't
listen to ac we listen to audio devices
so what all that stuff is smoking
mirrors
the name of the game is is the sound of
my audio system improved
so i could pick 100 different pieces of
audio equipment and test that obviously
is not practical but i just grabbed the
topping a90 that's on my desk ultron
that i use for headphone testing
and first fed it just from ac mains and
just did a you know quick setup for it
and we can see that his noise is 140
decibel i mean it's distortions minus
140 decimal and when you add noise and
distortion together it's at minus 120
and that's 5 db better than your best
case threshold of hearing so this device
just plugged into the dirty mains has no
need to anything to be cleaned up it's
not in the song cleaning internal
uh on this thing but an interesting
thing happened i was getting ready after
i ran this test i just turned on the
trip light before connecting anything to
it so i it's just trip light just
plugged into the ac but topping a90 is
still hooked up to my wall
as soon as i turned it on and it was
sitting where it's sitting now on top of
you know analyzer and you know i've got
a rack in here it's metal and and the
cables were all xlr shielded look at the
home that it induced right away uh this
is a honking big transformer generating
massive magnetic field and that magnetic
field is like a halo that's leaking into
everything around it and
indeed it managed to corrupt my
measurements and induce
you know this mains
hum at 60 hertz now i said minus 130 db
is still reload audibility but know that
there's damage done in here objectively
our system got worse the moment we
turned this on now
so if you're going to use it sort of way
the heck away from stuff uh on this
thing and because it you know it is a
big transformers in there and this is a
low power device you can get a bigger
ones but we have bigger magnetic fields
that they create so right away we see
that it can cause problems and indeed
when i route things through it now this
time it is powering the topping a90
sorry
uh we see that the mains leakage is in
here and it shows up just just as if you
know we hadn't plugged anything into it
but outside of that nothing's changed
right our output of our dac is the same
our headphone amplifier preamp is the
same
noise and distortion is still dominated
but inherent noise of the device so it
didn't change this device is just as
transparent as it was before this week
and uh certainly after this tweak is
it's just as well now common critics
some people get is that oh that's at one
frequency how about at all other
frequencies maybe it's doing something
else well the standard test i run has an
uh where i test the noise and distortion
at every frequency from not every
frequency but step through it from 20
kilos down to 20 hertz but the capture
bandwidth is 90 kilos that way we can
capture a harmonics of of 20 kills which
would be at 40 60 80. so we captured
that many of them and we capture all
that noise spectrum uh above audible
back but we can see that the two graphs
the red and the blue land right on top
of each other there is no difference at
all other than a little glitch in here
just a run to run variation so
at no frequency is the improve is there
any improvement
some i don't usually bother responding
to it but people keep latching onto this
timing and i'll analysis what happened
timing domain there may be something
good happens in timing domain first of
all this thing is a transformer it's a
low pass filter so it actually doesn't
like high speed signals doesn't like
sharp transients because those have a
lot of high frequency content when you
filter out the highs the device becomes
slow so
this is a slow device so if you think
something good is going to happen
because the slow it's a you know
improved transients it can't do that
because
it's nature is to slow those down but
anyway i run an impulse test and uh you
can see it with the raw ec and you can
see it with the
um going through the isolation
transformer indeed if i plot them both
together inside the software the two
graphs land on top of each other you
can't see one from the other
now one of the reasons i don't run these
tests is that a lot of caveats go in
there you might say well what are all
these ranking over here i thought you
said it was an impulse should be just a
stick well no if it's just a spike means
you have to have infinite bandwidth this
test has that audible band band with 20
kilohertz and when you filter everything
about 20 kilos
physics tells you nature tells you that
you cannot have an impulse response as
infinite bandwidth uh 20 kilohertz is
way below
infinite bandwidth so you get naturally
you get ring in pre-imposed ranking
but that's just this is just the way the
signal processing of this measurement uh
works uh but regardless of what
measurement does there was no impact one
was the other we still have a sharp
focus of the sharp spike in here that
how long it took to settle down or you
know go up identical in both cases so
there was nothing that this device did
in a timing domain
that
made a difference whatsoever on this
now i should say that
you know some again i don't my focus
isn't to measure electrical uh
performance of these things i i give it
the benefit of doubt that it does
everything it says
and one of the things it should do
is that if some kind of noise source
goes on the hot and neutral of your
wires and it's exactly the same
that means that between the two pins the
difference would be zero then that won't
by definition be able to get to the
other side so if you have
something that induces identical noise
to both pins it will isolate and block
that and there may be scenarios where
that could be helpful
uh or by chance and luck you may
eliminate some noise and things so
my focus isn't to say that it doesn't do
that i'm saying actually the opposite
let's say it does do that but just
remember that the uh this device doesn't
provide isolation for your safety ground
which is what is used
in rca connections between two devices
that rca outside shell is connected to
the chassis just the same usually unless
you know if you got a double insulated
device but even then it's probably
hooked up that way but anyway
at that isolation that people think oh
i'm blocking the noise from ground isn't
provided by this and if you hack it you
have an unsafe device unsafe situation
and for what benefit there is no benefit
there's no measurable benefit and i can
tell you there's just absolutely not a
hair has changed other than for the
worst with some mains uh
inducement in this but you know you look
at the full spectrum of what's happening
audio this is not just one number or a
sign ad i'm showing you i'm showing you
a full four year transfer that as every
little tick in here has every bit of
respect around noise and distortion all
in capsule in what happening in your
audible band and nothing nothing nothing
has changed and again we do the same
thing with wide bandwidth and nothing
has changed so all of this always points
to the same reason why these devices
don't even begin to make a difference is
because as i've explained before
the first thing your audio devices do is
convert ac to dc and conversion of a
sine wave to a flat line requires all
aspects of that sound wave to be thrown
out so of course we throw out the this p
then 60 hertz we throw out the harmonics
without the noise because we filter all
that stuff so first thing you learned to
do
i think i built my first power supply
when i was i know seven or eight years
old i learned from my older brother that
was into electronics and build a little
linear regulated uh power supply so and
what you do is you put regulators in
there and you put filters in there you
filter capacitors and the transformer
does some filtering as i mentioned so
this is the most basics and if you're
buying some kind of high-end audio
equipment
you know that better have like 14 stages
of filtering if you paid lots of money
for a high-end system
it comes with
tons of over design built into them
usually unless there's some voodoo
product you bought so that's the last
place you want to second-guess your
designer and say whoa you know as much
as smart as he was in building this 50
000 amplifier for me
aha he didn't know how to get rid of
noise coming in from ac i'm gonna go
stick something like this in front of it
so as i've shown you it just makes no
sense there's no logic to this thing of
why these work other than delay
intuition we think of them as like
filtering dirty water and getting clean
water at the other end those analogies
don't work if they work manufacturers
will be the first to show you
measurements like this and saying oh
look you know uh your apple fire's you
know five times more quiet now because
of this they could sell tons more
product if they had objective proof to
their credit trip light while they take
some liberties with their claims and
you know of this is isolated isolated
isolated it's great for surges great
fitness and this and that
they're not selling it to audiophiles as
an audiophile product and the fact that
people go buy them is most their fault
in that they're taking delay intuition
of isolation thinking that means
literally a moat as i explained
so this is not a you know something
damning about the uh you know trip lite
as a company or this product in the
specific if you know how to use them you
know how to modify them it's got
applications but not for fidelity
improvement which was the motivation for
this review where
uh you know member asked well do these
things improve sound fidelity and so
we've shown that the likelihood of them
providing any fidelity improvement is so
so so small because if it was gonna do
anything it would have done something
here we should have reduced this
distortion or noise for something he
should have done but it just doesn't do
that so
please don't go spend money on this
stuff these things waste power it's
another thing that could go bad
it's just you know and definitely
definitely do not modify them if you
don't know what you're doing you're
dealing with mains and safety issues
okay i hope you got something out of
this video i'll see you in a future one
bye-bye